signori è oggi devo registrare però c'è
un problema
quindi io ero indeciso se registrare o
andare di sopra a prendere questa
bottiglia in filaria nel culo
solo che mi sa che mi tocca registrare
sono poi non c'è il video di domani
quindi registriamo è che mi ricordo poi
è questa qua è ancora più lunga della
bottiglia
ragazzi sono con bob siamo soli ma
allora col flat adesso un completo sono
complete volevo dirvi che ho installato
una soundboard che sarebbe una roba
gioventù schiacci un tasto e partono le
cose tipo questo posso mettere quando
voglio ad esempio anche quando ci sono i
file posso fare così ed è una cosa
fichissima quindi se sentite sti rumori
strani in realtà sono io potrebbe anche
essere pietro è comunque ecco questa era
pietro va bene e se che non mi ricordo
neanche dove ho messo il joystick quindi
partiamo da dio lo sa ma sei tu questo
che è accaduto veramente
ma cosa sta vedendo fa6 un poliziotto
vestito da pc porca vacca di successo e
confiscato dei petardi e sportivo dicevi
dice vimar n ahi che male porta mamma mi
ha fregato più di cosa batte thinking
mamma mia che dolore ci spariamo su chi
cazzo è questo che è lesbica
porca vacca l'ho buttato così giù il
treno dopo di buttare giù guarda che ti
ha posto in treno mi piacciono a cercola
balistica sti colon e dimmi ho fatto un
casino col treno mi sarà successo
mi sa che non si parcheggia così
ci siamo eccoti amico ecco ti porto giù
nell'acqua ma nome in titanic stufa e tu
fai rose cosa ho visto va bene allora
regatiamo aspetta introdurre questa
lasciano un pò né titanic e quindi
questo è il sequel di titanic
noi dobbiamo andare non so dove però tu
dovresti prendere avremo la lega ti
faresti giorni deviare aiutarmi io ne
prendo uno tu prendi la madonna tolti
l'inter credo che stiamo in guardia sai
dove trovi il filo staremo mai finiremo
ok perfetto devi non da sinistra a
destra adesso pensa perché a destra c'è
il mare si muove grandissima parata
delle palle proprio aspetto aspettano
partite che ci sono io è ok premieremo
vai 3 ma non di qua mi avesse
sincronizzati uomo per incrocio tra
freddie mercury e pc guarda che sta
remando solo io si gira solo dalla mia
parma sta parla la mia sigilla guarda
che ho anche fondo m va avanti solo a te
perché sono io che girano ancora come la
ragioni la fisica di la pira
ma se mi sono quasi suicidato procede a
rivelare al mondo
no perché penso che sono arrivati in
tempo prima di affogati
mentre tutti le stragi nella bara ok
parti parti ma galizia come si parte non
c'è il motore che aiuta pietro aiutano
certo pietra vetro fa aiuto aiuto
no no la sigla stardom da chi l'ha visto
che apollo a favo
ma stai facendo per andare verso il moto
scapoli a sinistra perché spiega sofia
sofia bravo così pietro capo al gruppo
la vera di sofia
ci siamo ci siamo ci siamo no sono morto
affogato che fate perché all'inizio
pietro aiuto venga ma cosa venga non
riescono a notare fin lì credo che è
voluto far siciliana
questa è avvicinati di più ma non sei
capace a fare lauti cori e nicola amico
con cal
no no io ti giuro che se tra panati
ancora una volta io vado dalla vostra
famiglia infilo sull'anno proprio sopra
lano tutto il remo che pietro in mano
mancheremo di arrivare al motoscafo a
uno scafo si infatti è ok allora adesso
guido io vivo in tutto le maniche le
devi infilare deve essere devono
infilare pulire questo modo anche i due
temi quello io uso questo non mi
chiedere come no no dall'altra parte il
timone porca eva ma se così su un timone
perfetto mai perfetto evento a bordo ma
chiama bus ci siamo ci siamo ci siamo ci
siamo ci siamo ci siamo bellissimi
attenzione
abbiamo allora off ancora non aspettavo
di andare in mezzo alla all'arco questo
punto vediamo il motoscafo si conosca
mondo lo stiamo motoscafo motoscafo ben
di lo trascinano per e prendi trascinano
matematico ma cosa trascinano park che
stiamo avendo almeno si si guardò bravo
tecnicamente più in discesa
lavorava l'eletto youtube usa la forza
fisica pietro ma se tutti appendi sei un
peso in più ma che è in netta egli non
mi toccare ma dato ammazzo pomeriggio su
dio no ti preoccupa guarda che funziona
così io ti ho detto ma si sta
funzionando sul serio il 2 1 vai vai vai
vai è vero funziona funziona la madonna
guardali guarda lingotto si muove
guardalo tirolo di qua tiro di qua
gravissimo
la cosa per conto guardavi dei gran
lavoratori
poi ci ho fatto ci ha fatto solo ai vai
spingi spingi spingi ancora ecco che mi
lasci juba ciao pietro già pietro non
sono riuscito a lasciarti cola staccati
rai venuto scafo schifo allora aspetto
che teme arriva aspetta aspetta che
magari vado andata mazzarri per melo
girare io giro io giro io giro io giro
aspetta aspetta pietro aspetta non farlo
sei proprio perche gia pietro sono
risaliti a sinistra vero qui che si
calava da acimit sbloccato lavoro
pesante in mezzo alle boe ok aspetto è
sì perfetto a sinistra si sta da
sinistra d'altra parte girata micosi
tami da menchov ma lei l'ha presa male
cosa luglio mondo he ma io non mollo
cate aiuto e quindi un problema
gila a sinistra dall'altra parte ma dio
96 così io non ci voglio credere
uno è riuscito a salire adesso tu
mollano la palla non sei capace malati
faccio il gup allora fermi pazzini
perfetto era difficile mamma il cappello
da capitano maledizione adesso dobbiamo
approdare delicatamente sul delitto
aiuto per mike hall modo cioè punto
riteniamo arriva a fatica ma tu sei
scemo a queste scelte non ce l'ho fatta
guarda di come si parcheggia mamma mia
che pro
amico mio non so cosa dobbiamo fare
sicuramente c'è cosa c'è pure lui arrivò
di voi non è vero non è vero perché
avanti ai piatti ai piatti avanti avanti
avanti baratti perché ancora avanti
ancora avanti ancora avanti ancora
avanti ancora un po ancora un po gruppo
a loro non faccio fatta perfetto è
perfetto questa nave non può affondare
fatta di ferro poi ho sentito l'hanno
costruita il più di 20.000 irlandesi ci
crede lei di tantissimo
peccato che non c'è una bella figliola
che tenta di buttarsi di sotto dal retro
della barca che la nave faccio lo faccio
io lucera migliora ai baffi jack sto
volando mai fallo di brevissimo jack
siro da così lo senti sembra di volare
sì
[Musica]
vogliamo il deficit
e vabbè quanto lontano pesano onesto
gioco ma mi sa che un pò lenta questo è
infatti il motoscafo arrivo prima salta
veloce
[Applauso]
vaden tra loro scatti problema da
saldare
[Musica]
si no si dovevano farlo allora ti tiro
su andando avanti fermati no no no no è
morto no noti sono i sogni sono anche ai
tirati su
ora se rinascita all'isoletta sale è
amico di miti il suo amico io so mica
portati a mano ci pensiero e persiane
bomba che male e ma come saliamo aspetta
che il cuoio cioè i controlli di questa
cosa
in teoria mi sa che dobbiamo fare
porca vacca se fai così tu stai sopra
container device per ottenere 20 tiro su
sapro contenerlo ok ok
in realtà aggrappati ai cose grappa di
comando la fanta nebbia che sta
succedendo
ecco chi è che cosa succede ora formati
sono aggrappato mattino sotto quello
style.it dati sono un ingegnere aggiunto
si fidi si fidi mamma il peggio che non
è presto detto stai fermo dove cazzo
bilanciati fiscale poi bravissimo allora
qua è un casino perché devi staccare la
bar canova un casino non so se si deve
fare sinceramente se la catena che
sicuramente l'hai vista care ma non so
cosa la serva devi staccata devi
staccare la camera ok ma e l'altra per
fare la curva alla barca no no ce n'era
c'è la cia vera civ e lasciare la scena
amico non lasciarmi solo una veloce cosa
che serve staccate per far curvare la
barca no e serbi per lei casco declinati
in clienti si libri la no madonna sarà
anche stupido però dai ecco questo la ce
l'avremmo fatta perché uno avrebbe
tenuto il pulsante e l'altro sarebbe
salito sopra ma come facciamo se tu sei
rimasto rito ace la barca di rispondere
vieni qua sta qua no prima che prenda
parte anche come far curvare ai no siamo
a posto quindi
ed aspetta aspetta no amico di torno al
mio amico
ciao prendilo dal santa salta salta
si no
ciao
che bel gioco
[Musica]